ce dialogue qui commence aujourd'hui
entre nous vous françaises et français
qui cherchait en conscience où se trouve
le devoir qui vous interroger sur ce qui
convient de faire pour la france le 5
décembre prochain et moi candidat unique
de la gauche à la présidence de la
république qui vous demandent de
l'écouté et de comprendre pourquoi je
fais appel à vous oui ce dialogue qui
commence aujourd'hui
entre nous je l'espérais depuis
longtemps je suis candidat contre le
général de gaulle contre lui seul car
lui seul compte à droite mais ce n'est
pas une affaire facile 6 les entreprises
c'est parce que je crois de toute ma
conviction que nous sommes à la croisée
des chemins
le général de gaulle se fait
certainement de la france une idée
respectable mèze
il oublie le plus souvent de s'occuper
des français or où en seront les
français dans dix ans sans débouchés
puisque on les prive de l'europe
et puisque on casse le marché commun
sans avenir puisque on stérilise notre
économie puisqu'on lésine sur les
crédits de l'éducation nationale puisque
6 % seulement des filles et les fils d
ouvrier et paysan accéderont aux postes
de responsabilité dans notre société
puisque il nous faudrait trois fois plus
de chercheurs scientifiques puisqu'on
sortir de l'école des milliers de jeunes
gens iront s'inscrire au chômage
mais cette situation est sans doute
normal si l'on songe le général de
gaulle se pose d'un problème qui
concernait nos pères tandis que moi et
toute la gauche avec moi j'essaie de me
poser les problèmes qui concerneront
novices
je sais bien que l'actuel chef de l'état
n'ouvre pas la bouche sans expliquer que
ce qui va mal en france c'est la faute
de la quatrième république
comme le chante honnête autrefois les
muscadins du directoire c'est la faute à
voltaire c'est la faute à rousseau
mais soyons sérieux on voudrait tout de
même que la vème république qui a
maintenant sept ans atteignent enfin
l'âge de raison
en vérité depuis la dernière guerre
mondiale la france ne pas retrouver son
équilibre politique nous sommes allés
d'un extrême à l'autre sous le régime
procéderait précédent le parlement avait
accaparé tous les pouvoirs
la quatrième république s'est enlisé
dans les guerres coloniales
elle a fini dans l'anarchie et personne
ne la regrette la vème république elle
s'étend régime propriété personnelle du
général de gaulle est tellement mieux
c'est la pression que si le chef de
l'état malgré les atteintes de la veut
encore sept ans de pouvoir
ce d'abord parce qu'ils ne voient autour
de lui et parmi ces annick personne qui
soit digne d'assumer la fonction
et c'est bien ce qu'il voulait dire
l'autre jour lorsqu'il proclame et moi
ou le néant
c'est ensuite parce que lui partent il
sait bien que son régime est perdu elle
est enfin je le crains parce qu'il a
cessé de croire dans les chances de la
france se préfère cela vous l'attitude
d'un winston churchill qui en pleine
gloire et son parti battu adresse ses
voeux de réussite à ses concurrents plus
heureux car au delà des hommes quelles
que soient leurs mérites l'histoire
continue et s'est douté de son pays que
de se croire il remplace à l'est
républicain par conviction
autant que par tradition combattre le
pouvoir personnel est il bien sûr qu'en
1965 la majorité des français tiraillé
par une propagande de caractère
totalitaire et fatigués qu'ils sont de
cette république anonymes ou plutôt de
cette république aux mille et un visages
qu'ils ont vu défiler depuis un demi
siècle est il bien sûr que la majorité
des français soit hostile au pouvoir
personnel
certes ce n'est pas nouveau on a déjà vu
cela dans notre histoire une république
impuissante des républicains divisé et
cela produit selon le cas 18 brumaire
avec le premier de bonaparte ou 1 2
décembre avec le second
rien d'étonnant dès lors si le 13 mai
1958 nous a rendus charles de gaulle
seulement voilà qu'est ce que le pouvoir
personnel sinon l'abandon par près de 30
millions de citoyens français de leur
destin dans les mains d'un seul homme
sinon l'abdication de la souveraineté
populaire au profit d'un guide ou d'un
mètre
c'est parce que l'a compris cela que la
gauche pour la première fois depuis 30
ans c'est enfin réunis c'est pour cela
que pour la première fois depuis trente
ans la gauche autour de moi s'est
rassemblée
face à une droite dominé sans doute par
la personnalité du général de gaulle
mais profondément divisé la gauche
contre la droite
peut être pensez vous que ces mots sont
bien vieux et qu'il ne signifie plus
grand chose je vous les abandonne si
nous sommes d'accord sur le reste c'est
à dire si nous admettons qu'il y a dans
toute société
ce que révolte l'injustice et ceux qui
sont accommode ceux qui refusent de
changer par indifférence ou bien par
intérêt quoi que ce soit aux structures
du passé
et ceux qui au contraire recherche dans
le présent les chances de l'avenir et
bien moi ce que je vous propose c'est un
froid et un choix dans tous les domaines
extérieurs intérieurs économique et
sociale ou bien vous voulez que le
général de gaulle ou son successeur que
vous ne connaissez pas encore mais qu'il
vous imposera un jour ou l'autre des
sites de tous à votre place ou bien vous
voulez décidé vous même et comme tous
les grands peuples du monde qui ont
accédé à la démocratie assumer
pleinement votre fonction des citoyens
mais si vous vous contenter d'élire une
fois tous les sept ans un président de
la république quitte dans l'intervalle à
le laisse libre d'agir à sa guise comme
un souverain absolu alors faudra-t-il
trois collègues français s'estiment
moins dignes ou moins capables que les
anglais les américains les allemands les
italiens les suédois recrue 16 encore
qui eux exercent constamment un contrôle
sur ce qui les gouvernent mais j'ai dit
qu'il fallait choisir
et voici des exemples fabriquer la bombe
atomique de pensée pour elle des
milliers de milliards d'anciens francs
comme le veut le général de gaulle
plutôt que de construire les écoles ou
les logements dont nous avons besoin
comme je le demande
c'est un choix à faire mais qui vous
concerne et qui vous regardent un seul
avion mirage iv porteur de bombe
atomique qui sera démodé dans cinq ans
coûte plus cher que 300 logements de la
flemme refusé comme l'a fait le général
de gaulle d'arrêter les expériences
nucléaires qui polluent la prospère et
qui fera dès leur naissance
la santé de nos enfants
plutôt que d'inviter le monde comme je
le demande a cessé cette course
infernale au surarmement c'est un choix
à faire mais qui vous concerne et qui
vous
à s'enfermer comme le général de gaulle
dans un nationalisme étroit assorti d'un
jeu compliqué de coalition et
d'alliances en gens qui ont déjà
précipité les peuples au 19ème comme au
xxème siècle dans les pires catastrophes
la guerre des revanche d'autres guerres
des vainqueurs des vaincus
jamais les mêmes et pendant ce temps
l'europe ruiner les peuples pantelant
plutôt que d'essayer comme je le fais de
bâtir une europe scène solide unis ou
que de renforcer l'arbitrage
international
c'est un squat à faire mais qui vous
concerne et qui vous regardent imposer
un plan dit de stabilisation qui bloque
les salaires sans freiner les prix qui
entretient volant de ce beau mâle qui
stoppe l'essor de notre industrie comme
le fait le gouvernement de monsieur
pompidou plutôt que d'adopter un plan
d'expansion continue qui assurent le
plein emploi qui créent de nouvelles
richesses qui dirige les investissements
productifs qui fait confiance aux
français dans leur capacité de travail
et de production
comme me le demande c'est un choix à
faire mais qui vous concerne qui vous
regarde le taux d investissement
productif en france entre 1961 et 1964
0% l'allemagne 16 %
lequel des deux pays dans dix ans sera
le plus jeune est le plus riche accepter
que leur revenu global de notre
agriculture baisse de 3 % chaque année
que le quart des salariés français
perçoivent moins de 55 mille anciens
francs par mois
on discute à perte de vue sur la
misérable la location des personnes
âgées comme le fait le gouvernement de
monsieur pons vidéo
plutôt que de se battre pour la justice
sociale
comme je le fais avec toute la gauche
c'est un choix à faire mais qui vous
concerne qui vous regardent accepter
qu'on ne construise que 400 mille
logements par an
quand il en faudrait cinq cent mille et
qu'en même temps on laisse des fortunes
scandaleuse s'édifier sur la spéculation
foncière comme le fait le gouvernement
de monsieur pompidou plutôt que de
donner aux gouvernements et aux communes
le moyen de mettre un terme à cette
situation s'est enfin froid à pair qui
vous concerne et qui vous regarde
hier c'était la république les députés
aujourd'hui c'est la république d'un
seul homme demain il faut bâtir la
république des citoyens et c'est pour
cela que je vous disais tout à l'heure
que cela que selon le choix qu'on fait
c'est la droite où c'est la gauche et
les objectifs essentiels de la gauche
c'est de rechercher dans la société les
moyens de fonder de bien-être et le
bonheur de l'homme cet objectif impose
une politique extérieure qui soit au
service de la paix impose une politique
intérieure qui soit au service de la
justice
mais je n'aperçois ni l'une ni l'autre
au bout de la route que nous désigne le
général de gaulle voilà pourquoi je
voulais vous parler
[Musique]